so often I talk about how
video games are a wonderful place to start,
including more gender inclusive language
and also the experiences of queer and trans identities.
when I talk about this,
lots of people tell me Blossom,
Animal Crossing doesn't gender the characters.
that is amazing
if you're playing the game in English,
but if you play in Spanish, that is not the case.
it still asks for your gender.
I'm super happy that Animal Crossing did a
great, wonderful,
amazing job of not gendering the characters in English.
however, let's start doing that in all languages,
because video games are a wonderful place to start,
including things like neopronouns
and to stop gendering language and all.
see you in the next one!